so let's see if we can find the limit as
x approaches negative one of six x
squared plus five x minus one
now the first thing that might jump out
at you is this right over here this
expression could be used to define uh
the graph of a parabola and when you
think about this i'm not doing a
rigorous proof here a parabola would
look something like this and this would
be an upward opening parabola
looks something like this it is a this
graph visually is continuous you don't
see any jumps or gaps in it and in
general uh a part of
a quadratic like this is going to be
defined for all values of x for all real
numbers and it's going to be continuous
o for all real numbers and so something
is continuous for all real numbers well
then the limit as x approaches some real
number is going to be the same thing as
just evaluating the expression at that
real number so what am i saying i'm just
going to say it another way we know that
some function
is continuous
is continuous at some x value at x
equals a
if and only if all right that is if or
if
if and only if the limit
as x approaches a of f of x is equal to
f of is equal to f of a
so i didn't do a rigorous proof here but
just it's conceptually not a big jump to
say okay well this is this is just a
standard quadratic right over here it's
defined for all real numbers and in fact
it's continuous for all real numbers and
so we know that this expression it could
define a continuous function so that
means that the limit
as x approaches a for this expression is
just the same thing as evaluating this
expression at a in this case our a is
negative 1. so all i have to do is
evaluate this at negative 1. this is
going to be 6 times
negative 1 squared plus 5 times
negative 1
minus one
so that's just one
this is negative five so it's six minus
five minus one which is equal to
zero
and we are done